this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you thank you Vinnie for the
introduction Thank You Franny for the
invitation and indeed it's I'm very
grateful to vinay um and Alan laakso who
have given me a very interesting context
to think about for these last five years
grounded some of our naive ideas about
plant physiology and its relation to
engineering and so it's nice to be here
and see more of the faces of
horticulture at Cornell so I'm going to
tell you about models models of
transport processes in xylem and phloem
and as I wrote in my abstract these are
both mathematical models and physical
models uh no plants though no no plant
models but we'll try to make connections
to what is observed in plants and I've
questions for you about what might or
might not be observing and observable
and what might be interesting questions
to pose with these models and so this is
a the work of a large number of people
the group of former postdoc Dave sessoms
Vinay was about to finish and go off to
start his own lab Olivia vents on tues a
current post doc Michael Santiago here
in the audience a PhD student in
mechanical engineering Eric Huber
another PhD in mechanical engineering
and Jean Comte who was a summer student
who worked with me and with a bob
Turgeon on the first example I'm going
to speak to you about so um first I want
to say that we were inspired by plants
and I wish I was just telling Neil that
as you look at a plant you actually see
an engineering system you see the
engineering processes there's quite a
lot of translation that has to be done
but once that translation is done a lot
of the processes from the molecular
through the macroscopic map on to
chemical engineering in particular and
so we've been interested in
transpiration and the material science
of what makes transpiration profitable
I'm going to speak to you about very
briefly about a question about
regulating flow in the xylem and more in
more detail about sugar translocation
the phloem loading process and then show
you a physical and mathematical model of
what how failure occurs and how failure
is coupled with in the complex
architecture of the of the xylem and
then point to for example recovery as an
open challenge for us and for plant
science to consider so why how do I get
money for this I guess it's important
well it that in fact um plants do things
that we don't do or we don't do well and
so for example the transpiration process
it could be a coupled into the right
materials could be the basis for a heat
transfer system technology that would be
extendable out to a building scale
vehicle scale and could be very valuable
and the Air Force pays us to look at
questions about how to use liquids under
tension in the context of heat transfer
you've heard from Vinnie and from Allen
laakso about a micro technology that
could be a basis for communicating with
plants by measuring water potential I by
controlling liquids in the way that
plants control is a topic that we're
just beginning with a new student is
that the the extraordinary a process
that plants use to live in with their
roots outside of the water table to be
able to extract the pure liquid water
that they need to live from sub
saturated soils that's a kind of truly
magical seeming process from an
engineer's point of view a type of
reverse reverse osmosis that we simply
don't do and it would be very nice if we
could so I'm going to tell you today
though about our thinking that's about
plant processes and I'll try to keep it
in the plant context as much as possible
and in particular i'm going to talk i'm
going to talk first about down about
getting the loading process and this is
a topic that i pursued with bob Turgeon
and you'll see that he is has a very
strong imprint on this field and on our
particular question
um and then about very briefly about
questions of local control of
permeability that may be part of
manipulating flow within the xylem and
finally this question of cavitation in
mimics of xylem the segmented structure
of the xylem tissue so I'm going to jump
right into a phloem loading and um give
you an overview here from with a cartoon
from from Bob publication of a few years
ago a Bobbitt reviews the ideas of some
plastic passive loading where it's a
purely diffusive process with continuous
synthesis generates a gradient and
concentration diffusing into the intern
an intermediary cell and the sieve
elements and pulling in water and
driving flow a version a kind of hybrid
active passive process which is quite
intriguing that I believe is Bob's
invention his baby is a the trap a
trapping mechanism where biological
energy is expended in the middle of a
passive process to presumably increase
the gradient of sucrose concentration
and improve translocation rates for
example and finally familiar one of the
I think the most familiar active process
where you have a ATP ATP ace actually
pumping again directly using a
mechanical or chemical energy to invert
this gradient and drive translocation
and so this is a one of the signatures
that Bob and others use of something
other than passive is that a passive
species is obliged to bring sucrose
concentration or photosynthate more
generally concentrations hi everywhere
in the mezzo fill in order to drive this
concentration gradient to drive passive
diffusion whereas ah these two active
mechanisms have a way of segregating
sugars to avoid having
the entire leaf bathed in high
concentrations of photosynthate and one
of the one of the important ideas that
motivates the thinking about loading and
loading strategies the idea you don't
want your leaves with excessive
photosynthate concentrations because it
leaves you as an attractive leafy green
thing to eat for species and I sure
there are other ideas out there but
that's the one that's caught in stuck in
my mind and so in general this active
mechanisms minimize the photosynthate
concentrations and should although it's
hard to get direct evidence change the
translocation rate or the export loading
rate so I'm going to show you some
recent work or relatively recent work
from the detergent lab where they I
think get the most convincing picture of
this polymer trapping process and so
here we have a this enzyme that is going
to do a so called a polymerization or
oligomerization of the sucrose to create
in particular stachyose a4a for sugar
species and somehow keep it segregated
here and influence translocation and so
this is an example where the detergent
group identified the one of the players
in this oligomerization process and was
able to knock it down and what we see
here is that indeed this this species is
a polarizer oligomers ER has
significantly more of these raffinose
family oligosaccharides in the leaves
then a passive loader which has
essentially none or and they
successfully knock down this
oligomerization and the consequences of
this were that um the the knockdown case
i failed to get rid of all that
photosynthetic and ended up with these
very high concentrations of the classic
passive loader
and further this had consequences on the
global health of this knockdown case so
this is a strong suggestion that this
oligomerization process is part of
improving the translocation efficiency
allowing the plant to drive export
without building up excessive
concentrations of photosynthetic product
I also know I don't have it on the slide
but that they've nicely demonstrated in
this paper that these these enzymes were
localized in the local intermediary cell
or companion cell of the phloem so the
phenomenon again for this particular
loading process is that it's simplistic
unlike actives the classic active
process it goes through plasmodesmata
it's it has this enzymatic conversion
but you can think of as a kind of a
bootstrap it seems like a bootstrapping
process on top of a passive mechanism or
putting in energy in an odd place in
this pump it has this segregation
characteristic segregation of sugars in
the intermediary cell and appears to
have more efficient translocation so the
questions are we'd like to build a model
that would couple to water relations and
I'm going to emphasize I think it's in
crucial that you coupled to the all the
way to the xylem to think about how
loading occurs so this this we have to
add ingredients over here in terms of
coupling to the xylem on the impact of
polymerization and segregation on rates
of translocation the relationship
between in particular pumping the
ability to export efficiently and
segregate is this segregation part of
the the mode of operation of this
trapping mechanism and we can then look
towards putting some constraints on what
the plasma desmond must be like again
this is simplistic we don't think of
plasma desmona as
being very specific poor proteins that
have the ability to select between two
small molecules like sucrose and stack
eo's but here they they seem to be in so
we can be good to think about what a
plasmodesmata in this particular class
of plasmodesmata must look like so we
with guidance from Bob I took images
like this showing intermediary cell
mesophyll and and phloem and this being
the special membrane that contains these
a special plasmodesmata and we built a
new cartoon inspired by Bob's original
cartoon but in in particular has
particular additional ingredients like
being coupled to the xylem and a
well-defined a typically negative water
potential okay and here we have the
potential to be drawing in water
directly into the mesophyll and water
into the intermediary cell where the
enzyme is a processing the sucrose into
oligomers with eventual possibility that
this is not which you wouldn't expect to
be a perfect osmotic membrane to select
between sucrose and stachyose okay and
so we're going to this has a hydraulics
in it it's got it's going to flow their
beef low speeds of the unities fees
eventually i'm not going to have them
out explicitly but we're going to get to
some reflection coefficients effective
reflection coefficients for this a
plasma Des Moines brain that's acting
like an osmotic membrane we're going to
account for diffusion I'm going to run
I'm going to run the enzymatic
kinematics at zeroth order V Max okay we
can do this with for Michaela smitten
but I'm going to run it at zeroth order
and then we're keeping track of
stachyose sucrose and this concentration
of enzyme is embedded in this enzymatic
rate so just to remind you again that
underneath everything i'm going to show
you we have a hydraulic ver a simple but
a hydraulic architecture of these two
components of the leaf with a plasma
decibel member
each coupled to the xylem and then
coupled down to an unloading zone
somewhere in the route or a fruit or
somewhere else we're going to keep this
very simple in fact we're going to just
say that unloading is not limiting we're
going to keep the unloading the root
pressure in some sense in the phloem
going to be 0 it's going to be easy to
unload but it's putting in loading
limitations is is a possibility so what
is what is the munch mechanism go back
to the beginning passive mechanism is
the munch hypothesis on and we're going
to so I'm going to start by a reduced
version of our model that oh wait right
now this is just the passive it's
passive because I don't have any enzymes
in here and I'm going to for now just
keep a just allow sucrose to passively
diffuse across this membrane not allow
water to be loaded into the mesophyll
and and think about the a what controls
the concentration of sucrose that pulls
in water and drives the munch the munch
pump okay and so is the four equations
is although be there for unknowns here I
need to know the flow rates of sucrose
the flow rate of sucrose enough water
concentration in the intermediary cell
and I'll just point out that in these
coupled equations there is the classic
munch process which is to say there is
sucrose get into this pocket that's
coupled to the water potential we have
to have an osmotic strength that can
overcome the water potential and a piece
that isn't often considerate is that I'm
going to emphasize is this conservation
of shook roast is that this the same
thing that's that much is trying to give
you which is Florida carrier sucrose is
sweeping away your concentration
gradient so that the concentration that
driving that osmotic process is
inversely proportional to the flow that
it's creating okay so there's that
coupling that is is is crucial in
closing the mooch process and in fact
what it
it we Jean a cold day who built this
model identified a dimensionless group
and this is one of the things that we do
in our field is to try to group the
parameters in a way that characterizes a
process and in particular this loss of
concentration due to the water flow is a
competition between the flow of water
and the diffusive flow of sugar and it
can be right written like this it's got
the permeabilities the hydraulic
permeabilities a characteristic
difference in pressure this is a
negative number it's being overcome by
this osmotic number and this is a ditch
a diffusive coefficient of diffusion
diffusion coefficient for this membrane
a so-called mass transfer coefficient
and so this captures the impact of
convection on the trapping process and
I'm going to show that it's a useful
it's a useful number to have so here's a
case where we're going to consider that
the plant has a desired Turner say in
its meza fueling keeps the levels of
sucrose in the mesophyll at a constant
level and we're going to ask what
happens when I turn on the reaction rate
the queue polymerization is going to be
a homogeneous reaction rate turning a
sucrose in the staff ghos and so first
i'm going to turn on the polymerization
with a low a low of phloem in fact this
is a high flow impermeability i have
this backward so that there's lots of
flow our so-called flushing number is
bigger than one and what we find is that
absolutely we benefit from the trapping
mechanism by consuming I'm going to I'm
going to the extreme where the enzymes
are fast enough that I use up all the
sucrose it diffuses across and of course
in the monks picture here the red line
being the concentration of all of
sucrose up between the mesophyll and the
intermediary cell if I use up all the
sucrose I absolutely improve the rate at
which I move sucrose into the flow okay
so trapping with high flow rate low flow
rate it does it's definitely going to in
prove or polymerization let's say
oligomerization will definitely improve
the rate of export relative to nope no
oligomerization but uh it there's no
segregation in this case I'm getting rid
of all of the photosynthate that gets
into the intermediary cell before it can
pile up okay so here we have a polymer
without trapping okay and it is useful
but it doesnt it's this i'm showing you
apple on a so-called purely passive
loader if i turn it on the other hand in
presence of a large resistance here i
have this I was thinking resistance here
law a small permeability for the rest of
the transport phloem I get bolt I I can
use up all my sucrose drive more
diffusion higher loading rates but also
if I'm not flushing it away too quickly
I can end up with segregation and
characteristic this type of picture of
the the loading and segregation of the
photosynthate into the phloem elements
so this just this we've looked at this
in a variety of scenarios here i'm just
showing the ratio this is looking at
segregation the ratio of intermediary
cell concentration total of all sugars
versus in the mesophyll as a function of
the this the flow rate the non
dimensional flow rate and we see that we
get we can we can get very large
segregation but we can also have
polymerization going on without any
without any segregation here mesophyll
concentration below intermediary cell on
the other hand and this is I think an
important conclusion from this model
under any circumstance here increasing
the polymerization rate increases the
equivalent sucrose export rate it is
always a good idea to polymerize alright
whether you segregate or not okay and
I'll just say briefly that we this I'm
showing us in the the simplest case but
if we go back to a full
action for water relations in a sense
and the possibility of having
intermediate reflection coefficients for
this plasmid as well membrane are these
same trends hold and these are almost
identical-looking plots but and we are
understanding right now is that localize
polymerization always is beneficial from
the point of view of export but does not
depend on segregation so this this is a
question for Bob why severed a ok and
I'm going to tell you just the next few
slides segregating is not trivial you've
got bills you've got to turn these plans
with Edmond into an osmotic membrane but
why it seems to suggest that there's
some other reason to segregate that
doesn't have to do with improving the
rate of export okay now so that's
something that we've been discussing we
need to continue discuss but I'll be
interested in if there any suggestions
so one interesting idea that emerged
from Zhang's model is and in here Bob
pulled together this set of data showing
that a lot of passive lawyers in
particular trees which surprisingly
think trees are always classified the
big guys you have to export / meters and
meters and meters are all paths okay but
they do polymerize oligomers okay they
oligomers they don't segregate but what
Joe has shown in this model is that any
polymerization is good polymerization
you're taking away that sucrose
increasing that gradient and so there's
some possibility that these guys are
another version of polymer trappers that
take advantage of the increased
translocation efficiency without a
worried about segregation okay so I'm
going to come now just finish with this
topic with questions about the plasma
desmona so I alluded to this that it's
not obvious we usually
of plasma Desmond I'd be big big port
okay many molecules across so how are we
distinguishing between a sucrose and a
stachyose which a reasonable hydraulic
dimension of the suit of a sucrose would
be one nanometer and a stack us just 1.4
in diameter okay so and this is
micrograph of the special type of plasma
desma that are found in these in these
trappers but it's still a pretty big
structure and of course we're thinking
about this is an annular lumen we're
thinking about a sub structure but it's
not easy to see how you get a
selectivity based on that so we're going
to try to build a simple model and this
is partly to check an idea that Bob
first mentioned to us in our first
conversation which is that partly this
could be hydrodynamic selectivity okay
once we're going to have a pressure
gradient a water potential gradient in
particular between the the mezrab fill
and the intermediary cell and this is
going to drive a convective flow through
that same pore through which sucrose and
stachyose are trying to diffuse sucrose
is going to be going with the flow
stachy OHS is going to be going trying
to diffuse against the flow so to the
extent that you can bootstrap their
system and get it going if it's going to
be tending to give you the selectivity
it's going to be tending to exclude
stachyose from back diffusing and that's
what this first this is for a very
generic diffusion and convection to Zoey
flow through a pipe I appropriate for
macro scale when it says that even if we
have no absolutely no mechanism for
selectivity we can for the guys who are
trying to back to fuse ah we can get to
a ratio there's a ratio of the pore size
to the solute size at which you will go
from a back diffusion to convective of
expulsion of the stack eels
okay so this is a purely hydrodynamic
convection based mechanism by which you
could have this apparent selectivity and
segregation now we've gone on there are
we pick the simplest model to take into
account essentially just sterics of the
poor with a dimension r and a solute
that has a dimension that's not far from
our and what we find is it and this
impacts as our changes it impacts both
the solvent and the solute and what we
can find is at very small ratios of poor
to solute so saying that the poor is
just a 1.5 fold what the solute is we
can find that in also that this steric
selectivity steric reflection
coefficient can give us a inhibit back
flow of the statues and in interestingly
the same model of hindered so-called
hindered transport by Dean at all
actually at very large pore sizes again
get can give us a purely convective
mechanism for selectivity so these are
going to summarize our the fans of this
in in this state diagram I'm bringing
back our flushing parameter keeping
track of the importance of convection
through the through from the xylem to
the phloem and keeping track of one non
dimensional geometry and piece of
information the pore size to the solute
sub and these are for these boundaries
are these lines or boundaries between
huge sea of non segregating cases and a
very small set of parameters that give
us segregation this is what i mean by is
not it's not easy to segregate to
segregate with a within the presence of
with this hindered transport model you
have to be at very low through flow
rates of water and there
very small ratios of the poor to the
solute sighs okay so if we take on a
typical ratio of stachyose to sucrose of
1.4 the poor has to just be a couple
nanometers across okay and let me remind
you that the poor is not this is a
picture that Bob pointed us to of this
annular region with obstructions in the
form of proteins okay that are coming
the plasma death mode has two membranes
it's this annular region that's free and
these we can think of as nano channels
and not just micro channels passing
passing in between this obstacle course
of protruding pro teams all right it's
as far as we know this is about how well
we understand that architecture okay
this blurry transmission electron
micrograph okay what we're pointing to
here is that within that bar if we're
going to if we're going to see we're
going to see a segregation we're going
to be at these those effective openings
between those proteins are going to be
very small indeed i'll just point out
that if we avoid his urance a week early
convective segregation can occur but
only for unrealistically large
differences in the size of the two
solute okay we can open up another
region where segregation occurs but it's
it's which seemed to be is pointing
again to the need for some sort of
selectivity at this point I'm putting it
into the difference in size of the two
these two molecules which is not
realistic so um Sutton the summary
summarize I think you don't have to go
far in terms of building a model in on
top of munch type ideas but you do need
to bring in water relations you do need
to bring in the xylem you do need to
bring in the convection that is the
through convection that is from the
xylem down into the trans
flow importantly oligomerization is
always a good idea if you're a passive
learner with some plastic paths it
always makes sense to do that um and
maybe a bunch of passive floaters that
we had not been thought of in this way
or in fact taking the advantage of this
the other hand are segregation is a
mystery from my point of view right now
Bob can have to explain it to me and
that finally their plasma Desmond in
some sense can be brought down to a
scale where they act like a poor protein
like a selected for proof and to do that
you not surprisingly have to get down to
a molecular scale now right now we have
essentially a billiard ball kind of
model of transport flow planning Deborah
but it points to the need in particular
you can't just have convective
selectivity you do need some what is
essentially a chemical like selectivity
in that plasmid as well membrane so i'll
be happy are there any questions right
now I'm just going to speed ahead
okay so I'm just going to go very
briefly through an idea that we explored
with Michael Santiago and vinay up that
is an observation in the literature that
the border pit membranes change their
permeability as a function of the
composition of this of the xylem sap and
one proposal for why they might be doing
this is is that the plan could actually
be modifying the composition of asylum
sap to change the permeability of its
xylem and direct flows within the xylem
tissue conduct at issue to deal with for
example gradients in composition of the
soil water potential thermal gradients
and so this is a classic this is an
observation of Martin Zimmerman in that
in the 70s it was followed up by magic
and magics maneki and macey holbrook a
little over 10 years ago and very
cleanly showed that with respect to
ionic strength millimolar zuv ionic
strength the permeability of xylem
tissue which is supposed to be this
passive conduit in fact changes okay and
in for example resistance goes down as
ionic strength goes up resistance goes
down with that pH going down so we're
coupling to some chemical characteristic
of the asylum and in this work an
important piece of this work is they
isolated passage through an individual
borrow pit membrane and showed that this
remained true and so they pinpointed the
border pit membrane as the source of
this variability they had a very clean
story they got into science you know
that that still have to have a clean
story since then the story is not so
clean in particular kosher and many
others have found that they their
species in which the this so-called ion
effect is backwards 0 and so on and so
what we're seeing just to clarify what
we're seeing here is the flow rate on
here a normalized flow rate with respect
to the zero ionic strength case so I'm
just going to point out that
you can see this in the paper that we
just came out that we looked at
explanation of this based on the what
so-called electrokinetic phenomena and
I'm pointing this out party to remind
you or make you aware of the fact that
there are electric fields in plants
during transpiration okay why well
because plant tissues are charged
essentially all tissues all materials
are charged in the presence of water
plant tissues are going to be negative
because of carboxylic acid groups in
particular ah and as you convict through
a poor for example through through the
border pit membrane on you're going to
carry the counter ions that are
associated with the charge tissue from
one end to the other that you're going
to lead to a polarization in the
electrolyte that is going to create an
electric field and in the what we're
looking at here on the so called electro
viscous effect that electric field
actually drives a net flow back and
reduces the amount of total flow you get
for a given pressure difference across
the system okay and so uh what I think
it's worth whether this is important to
any of you or to anybody this particular
electro viscous effect I don't know but
we could have tens of millions maybe a
hundred millivolts voltage difference
over very small different distances
within the xylem and of course that's
the polarization of a plasma membrane so
there's the potential to actually I for
for these electrical effects coupled to
flow to be part of for example signaling
so I'll just saw that on this model
there's a there's a big cloud we reduced
somewhat from the literature on these
effects but in taking the ones that had
a large range of the relative
permeability uh for a charge channel
verse
an uncharged channel as a function of
ionic strength and what we took here are
our predictions are this dotted line in
this solid line this is the lowest range
end of the range of surface charge that
we could find be to be reasonable for
tissues in the xylem and on the border
fit this is the high end of the range of
surface potentials or surface charge
densities and what we see is that a
reasonable part of this cloud fits our
predictions and one important aspect of
our predictions is that it's
non-monotonic this electro viscous
effect as we lower ionic strength into
the tens of millimolar range the Elector
the viscosity grows we have lower
permeability and then it plateaus and
rises up slightly again as we go towards
the ionized water okay ah and so we what
we can conclude from this is not that
this is the mechanism for electro
viscous effect or for the ions deck but
that it absolutely is going to be
present whether whether its dominant or
not we proposed some experiments that
can distinguish them and we're hoping we
or someone else is going to do them but
I think again the bottom line is that
there are certainly affects possible for
electric fields in xylem tissue and they
could be part of a signaling potentially
part of a refilling process or a
translocation okay so I'm going to
finish with um are are synthetic models
of plants and so this is what we some
simple structure like this we call a
tree and it's got two two zones where it
can exchange with the outside world if
its own that is is wetter will call the
root zone as dryer will call the leaf
and then we're moving this in the
silicon I so that for example we can
measure things quantitatively about the
state of water in this system and so we
can start putting in arc
sexual features like this segmented
quality of xylem and so first tell you
give you a little update on what Vinay
has been up to and tell you about one
version of this synthetic tree is we
call a tensiometer and essentially it's
it's a it's a leaf coupled to a pressure
transducer and our the context that
vinnie has told you about is that this
is what a tensiometer is called it's
called tensiometer today we'd like one
that extend the range of function by
several orders of magnitude and the form
factor so that for example this can
become an embeddable technology and so
the key to this and this is what we is
to find materials that can act like the
mesophyll and it's in relation to
transpiration and in particular hold on
to water with a meniscus that has very
high radius of curvature very small
radius of curvature order a few
nanometers so that we can get to
capillary pressure differences between
the liquid and the gas outside of tens
to hundreds of mega pascals so on this
we by going into silicon we can also
build transducers a direct to get
electrical signals as a function of
stress and these can be these are very
well behaved mechanical systems that
give us simple signal and can be
calibrated against well defined
pressures and the kind of what one of
the exciting things that the first
results that come out of this is to
truly visualize water and stresses well
beyond what
in the plant world and so this is an
example of a calibrated device we're
here is the voltage across this sensor
and here's the pressure across this
sensor and here's one where vinay just
put it on the bench and allowed it to
dry into very dry atmosphere and much to
our pleasure it failed but it failed at
over 300 bars okay over 30 mega pascals
and so we think this in any context of
creating liquids under tension this is
the largest negative pressure that has
ever been measured on and certainly in
the context of plant a plant like
mechanism of a porous membrane coupling
to a low water potential this is a
strong support of Dixon and Jolie and
Ashkenazi and all the others who put
forward a cohesion tension theory over a
hundred years ago it's kind of one of
the nice things I'll show you a few
times in such a system is that we can
also watch the consequences of tension
and so this is this is one of these
pockets of liquid are during the moment
when failure occurs and what you can see
here is a dramatically the extremely
violent event that cavitation or
embolization is okay so this is what you
see is that a turbulent flow is emerges
in a 25 micron gap it's a few
millimeters wide here we can also see
for better or for worse this is violent
enough that it starts to actually damage
our silicon and glass structure okay
around the edge it starts to debone and
so that's a nice opportunity in terms of
being useful this this is the anomaly
this over 300 bars is an anomaly but we
actually have on some 15 20 runs with
running these things to their stability
limit we they all go to over 10 mega
Pascal okay so it gives us a sense of a
new technology to couple the plant in
the laboratory they're starting to be
very well behaved and this is
a work of Michael Santiago fact what
this gives us is a new new measure of
the thermodynamics of water under
tension which has only been measured
along in fact this isotherm and what we
can see is that a calibrated tensiometer
agrees with the equation of state the
International equation of state at 20
degrees there's important questions
about the International equation of
state of water as you go to cooler
temperatures and that's one of the
opportunities Vinny actually just got
one of these into soil from the Venice
lab and what you can see is he got a
tensiometer that's going to nine bars in
a drying soil uh which is again showing
that we're now at a completely different
regime for tensiometer II then he's
currently accessible I'll also point out
it wasn't fast it was a slow experiment
and that is one of the challenges that
we can can address within this format by
changing the geometry of this system so
I'll just point out I we are interested
in people with large stress questions
okay deserts okay trees we would like a
excuses to be going to a hundred bars in
the soil or in your plant so let us know
so I'm going to finish with the
questions about failure about cavitation
and how it occurs and I'm going to point
to this there's this nice meta-analysis
across many studies that shows
surprisingly how many species live right
at their a fifty percent loss of
conductivity lines okay and even those
that don't they live it some 50 25
percent of Los conductivity which says
it plants every single day or are amble
izing cavitating and recovering and very
recently in this room we saw a the group
from Davis tell us about direct
visualization of embolism within
xylem vessels and even more intriguingly
refilling in real time within vessels oh
one of the of course we're not all lucky
enough to have Lawrence Berkeley Lab
across the street and what most people
do including vinay with Alan laakso and
tearing up in Geneva is to measure
acoustically a non-invasive method
method of getting information out about
the failure modes within the xylem
tissue and so this is just a collection
on grapevine of the number of acoustic
events versus water potential in a vine
and interestingly what would be nice is
if we could do learn more from these
non-invasive techniques is there some
way to do statistics and learn about the
dynamics in such a way that we could do
the inverse problem we get the sound we
hear it can we learn about the local
architecture that created it okay and
the dynamics that created so for example
in this data what we'll see it there are
times when it pulses okay they'll be
huge events and then nothing and huge
events and then nothing interesting also
there's a power law distribution and
events sizes like avalanches or stock
market crashes there's some interesting
dynamics that defines the size of these
events so one of the things that we've
been doing with this a synthetic system
is to create the segmented architecture
where we have here a vessel element a
coupled through this same nanoporous
silicon to other vessel elements and
then coupled to the outside world where
we can generate stresses by presenting
low water potential and so what we're
looking at here is uh three full
cavities one is in the midst of
cavitating and then this guy's empty
okay and so I'm going to show you some
movies like this now looking from the
top over a big array and what we're
doing is we're drawing these out into an
eighty-five percent relative humidity
atmosphere and what we were very pleased
to see is that we have these isolated
events ok this is robustness this is the
proposal at the text book proposal for
why that is I will remain segment is so
that a cavitation event doesn't spread
in an uncontrolled manner along the full
length of the xylem and that indeed is
what we see you can tell that the
dynamic is more complicated than that we
definitely do have some propensity to
drive to cala kate moore near the
highest stress zones ah but there's this
very rough dry in front that we see and
so this is surprising in a physical
science context a material if you start
extracting the liquid from it you think
it should drive from the outside where
the stresses are largest more
interestingly if you watch this in
detail what you'll see is that in fact
it doing something very regular you're
pulling in a steady manner and it's
responding in fact it has a series of
avalanche very controlled avalanches
that occur of a similar size and a
timing that seems to be a very strictly
controlled by something ok so the
something's going on to couple these
failure events alright and this just
shows that these correlations of this
time trail of avalanches goes out toward
tens of minutes to an hour so one thing
is that we can also hear these same
events just in fact using the same
acoustic transducer that goes into the
field we can hear these events they
create a strong a acoustic ultrasonic
shock arm and in fact it has very
similar signatures to the ones that we
see from woody species and so our first
hypothesis would these events are
triggering each other one appt one
cavitation event sends a coup stick
signal and triggers another or another
series of unfortunately though what I
show your correlations on this
10 5 10 minutes the ring down of one of
these acoustic events is just a
millisecond ok so these do have there's
interesting the fact that they created
acoustic signals but it can't be what's
coupling these events so we when we went
back to our data and look more closely
and in particular started to look at
spatial information about these
correlations what we saw was that if we
plotted the position between two
subsequent events versus the time
between those subsequent events we
actually had this cloud with a very
clear hole in it ok that uh within this
zone an event that occurs at time zero
inhibits the a second cavitation event
in this for this period of time over
this distance and in fact when we look
at this envelope on this inhibited zone
and in fact has a square root of time
behavior that suggests a diffusive a
diffusive phenomena so in fact what we
think and we quite convinced now is of
hydraulic suppression of adjacent events
and this I think relates to interesting
ideas about why plants are do go to
twenty five fifty percent of their
cavitation a possibility in a given day
and so very quickly what what we can
write down and this will be true for
plants as well is a diffusion equation
for pressure in this medium in the xylem
tissue any porous medium uh will have
some elasticity in this case in our very
rigid material its elasticity of water
and a permeability which is its Darcy
permeability and together these create a
diffusion constant for pressure and
pressure solves the time-dependent
diffusion equation and you know in this
problem this time dependent diffusion is
coupled to the kinetics of cavitation
which is a function of the pressure
that's being diffused around and so this
shows what our understanding of this
process is so here this is eric uber
model of those equations are just showed
and what we saw is the pressure
the pressure dropped coming in from the
edge creating a cavitation eventing this
first cavity that then sent out a wave
before the way it could reach it you're
the wave is going out of suppression
these two guys cavitate it before that
suppression wave could come and meet
them they all then spread out refill the
the medium with water that's freed up by
freed up by the cavitation event and
that's suppressed further cavitation
event for a period of time okay and so
this we believe this is now is from this
type of model of our same experiment we
see consensually one-to-one match of the
dynamics we get in our in our
experimental system and when with this a
couple pressure diffusion reaction
profits and so I think what's important
is that I've seen this proposed in the
literature this is an example of the
xylem serving a design of water serving
as a reservoir of water for the tissue
that doesn't happen so you have a
vulnerable zone they can attain and then
give you water to release tension in
transiently in the rest of the plant ok
so I'll finish up to connect this back
the inverse problem we would we now do
under one explanation for why we might
see these periodic events in acoustic
data at times we don't have an
explanation for this power law of
distribution but there's a nice
possibility now to look at other
architectures try to understand the
dynamics and design criteria for xylem
tissue and then what i'm showing years
in fact this same system will refill we
have tricks to get this system to mimic
refilling and that's an opportunity to
look at some of the proposals for how
siloam repairs so i'll finish with these
remind you that your your choice of
species to study their excellent
engineers and inspiration there are are
opportunities for
oh jeez both the interface with plants
and to go out into other places in the
world and then method models both
mathematical and physical like all
models are wrong but potentially can be
useful to restrain the way you think
about a system that you're a lack of
information on so with that I'd like to
again acknowledged in particular vinay
and Michael Olivier Jean and Eric for
their direct participation in this work
and thank you and you happy taking
questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu